look millions of households and families
are going to be worried sick by what are
massive increases in their energy prices
so many people have said to me here look
i may not be the hardest up but i'm
going to struggle to pay these bills
small business is saying you know we had
two years of covet and now we're
expected to meet these price rises
in a
meanwhile oil and gas companies are
making huge profits that they didn't
expect to make and i think almost
everybody would say that's not right
that's why labor that's why i've said we
need to have a freeze on those energy
prices do not let them go up to those
levels and pay for that in part by a
windfall tax on the oil and gas
companies on those excess
meanwhile you've got a government that
is missing in action and i think most
people looking in today would say that
is unforgivable from the government in
the middle of a cost of living crisis
you say that your proposed price freeze
would save households around a thousand
pounds that's not going to be enough is
it if energy bills are going to be over
three and a half thousand pounds in the
next few months will you need to do more
i've spoken to people across the country
they are really worried by the fact that
in october their average bills might go
up to 3 500 pounds up again in january
to possibly 4 000 pounds and they want
action taken when i say to them labour's
plan
is to freeze that not let those price
hikes take place they say that's a good
plan
and when i say to them we're going to
pay for that in part by a windfall tax
on the oil and gas companies who are
making much more profit than they
expected people say that's right they're
political choices here we either you
know
allow oil and gas companies to continue
to make those massive profits whilst
millions of people suffer this winter or
we do something about it the labour
party will not walk by we'll do
something about it
but your suggestion will cost nearly 30
billion pounds you say others say it
will cost more no one is suggesting that
electricity prices are going to be
coming down next spring so you'll need
another 30 billion pounds don't you
think that your policy could quickly
spiral to 100 billion pounds if prices
stay this high what we've got is a fully
costed comprehensive plan
for this winter which will freeze those
prices that is welcome news for so many
people at warrick today
that is a fully costed plan you haven't
got that from the government or anybody
else
i accept that in april may of next year
we need to look forward then to the
proposals in place and that's why i've
said alongside our plan we need medium
and long-term solutions we need to be
much more self-sufficient when it comes
to energy
a year ago
i said we should have a national mission
to insulate homes so many people are
paying huge bills for energy and heat
that's escaping from their homes we
could have a national mission to
insulate those homes
if the government had taken me up on
that challenge last year about two
million people would now have insulated
homes and their bills would be very very
low so yes alongside our plan for this
winter we need a medium and long-term
plan we've put that in place and my
challenge into the government is
where are you
join us in this challenge and do
something about it because at the moment
being missing in action is absolutely
unforgivable